Hello and welcome to fire of
learning England and France.
Today the two nations get along
comparatively pretty well.
Not always eye to eye on everything,
but you could definitely
say their overall friends.
This was not always the case.
This friendship comes after
over 800 years of animosity,
certainly not always at war in that time,
but from the Middle Ages to Napoleon,
England and France always had an eye on
each other and we're rarely afraid to
settle their grievances
the old fashioned way.
What was the reason for this
bitter endless rivalry? Well,
we can consider a number of factors.
Religion played a role for awhile.
Later on after the Protestant reformation
spread across Europe and the 15
hundreds Catholics and Protestants
overall developed hard feelings for each
other,
which often led to brutal conflicts,
conflicts from which France emerged for
many Catholic and England Protestant,
the two nations also deferred politically
and philosophically from time to time.
And when one nation was shaken up,
the other felt the effects.
The most obvious example of this being
the widespread effects of the French
revolution,
which England attempted to counter.
And of course when about any two groups
of people find themselves right next to
each other geographically,
they tend to compete for land,
power and resources
through war and conflict.
England and France are no exception,
but we can find examples of all
of these things across the globe.
What makes the rivalry between England
and France unique was the competition for
quite simply world domination.
Let's back up and start at the beginning.
Prior to each other,
England and Francis greatest enemy was
the vikings who ravaged both of these
nations while they were still evolving
into the ones we note today. England,
a part of an island took the harder hit,
but France suffered as well and the nine
11 and the French king actually gave a
viking warlord named Rollo in area of
land in the north to settle down in as
tribute. This region became known as
Normandy, the land of the north men.
Why am I telling you this?
Because these Normans preceded the
conflicts between England and France.
By the middle of the 11th century,
the Normans had become a mix of French
and vikings retaining the Viking Spirit
for exploration and conquest,
but speaking French and having adopted
French culture of Christianity and
military reforms.
The Duke of Normandy was technically
is subject of the French king,
but realistically,
the Normans were an independent nation.
In the year 10 66 the Normans under
Duke Guillaume invaded England and
[inaudible] better known as William
the conqueror became king of England.
This Norman conquest resulted in a
lot of changes to England in language,
law, culture, et Cetera,
but most relevantly politically because
the king of England was the Duke of
Normandy and therefore
technically a French subject.
Tension over power became inevitable as
England was drawn into the complicated
politics,
if France of the day 1154
in a very stereotypically
meaningful situation after a
succession crisis known as the monarchy,
Henry the second two became king
of England and Duke of Normandy,
but had also because of inheritance,
already rural.
These lands here as Duke of Aquitaine and
countable issue and thus ruled what is
referred to by historians as the
knowledge of Van Empire. As you can see,
these lands cut right through France and
the rights over these lands as well as
the rights to the Thrones of England and
France and selves became the source of
conflict for much of the medieval era.
The most notable medieval conflict
between England and France was the hundred
years war.
Another term invented by historians,
which actually refers to four separate
wars over the period of 116 years.
England was victorious in the early
phases of the war, but in the final war,
the French had achieved
their ultimate goals.
That is to say retaining territorial
integrity and political independence and
effectively won the war. The war is,
we're very draining to both nations,
but at the end of them we see the
transformation of these two and to true
recognizable nation states.
However,
the English were not necessarily done
after the hundred years war and in fact
the monarch would claim the title of King
or Queen of France until 1803 when it
was dropped in favor of the
depose monarchy. As Europe
entered the renaissance,
the rivalry between England
and France did not weather,
but the focus was about to change from
localized squabbles to the competition to
conquer the new world or really worlds
that the Europeans were beginning to
chart.
Around the year 1008 a group of Vikings,
unrelieved Erickson became the first
Europeans to reach the Americas.
Everyone ignored this and in 1492 the
Spanish under Christopher Columbus became
the first Europeans to reach the Americas.
Spain and Portugal quickly became the
first nations to establish settlements and
claim territory in the new world of
America as well as Africa and Asia.
And as time went on,
the Dutch Swedish Russians and of course
English and French would enter the game
as well. These nations, specifically
Spain, Portugal, England,
and France could realistically be called
the first world powers in the sense
that they were the first nations to
be able to have influence and project
military power across the globe.
The English and French were
late to the game comparatively,
but by the year 1700 it was clear that
they would be the most major world
players, specifically in
North America and South Asia.
Africa would not be heavily colonized
until almost two centuries later,
Spain and Portugal were in decline.
Sweden and the Dutch had been knocked out.
Russia was not heavily involved in
colonization and focused more on its own
contiguous territories and the rest of
Europe did not or could not make much
effort toward colonization. A number of
conflicts emerged in the 18th century,
which spilled over into other
theaters. Most notably, as I said,
the India and the coast of Africa.
The most important of these words was
what is called the seven years' war known
in America as the French and Indian war,
where it would actually last for nine
years from 1754 to 1763 the war remains
one of the most significant and world
history as essentially an 18th century
world war leading one side England
or more correctly at this point,
Britain and on the other
France hanging in the balance,
the fate of the world itself. If
one side, decisively one here,
it would affect not only Europe,
not only America and India,
but also even later colonization in
Africa, Oceania and the rest of Asia.
In 1763 Britain emerge victorious in all
theaters and thus happily sat upon its
place as the world's
unchallenged top colonial power,
but France was not done and quite
unhappy about this would later support a
rebellion and the British American
colonies that became the American war of
independence, which as they intended
Delta major blow to the British empire.
Nevertheless,
the British empire recovered and even
sought out Newlands like Australia and New
Zealand, while the rest of Europe failed
to keep up the 18th century is sometimes
referred to as the second hundred years
war because the two powers were quite
frankly in constant conflict following
the French and Indian war. As I said,
France was clearly on the losing
end and by the end of the century,
economic strain related to this constant
militarism was a major contributing
factor to the French revolution,
which toppled the old San regime and
establish the French republic. At first,
Britain laughed,
but when events became more serious,
the king and queen were executed and
the new republic establish itself by
defeating the major powers of Europe.
Britain recognize the situation
was serious when Napoleon
Bonaparte over through
the Republican government and crowned
himself emperor of the French.
It was clearly very serious.
France now challenged not only Britain,
but the whole of Europe as the military
genius Napoleon Bonaparte said about
intending to create an empire
extending across Europe for a time.
He was basically successful in doing so,
but though Britain was
one of his main targets,
he was never successfully able to reach
it. Britain was naturally Napoleon's,
most powerful rival and was the
forest rallying Europe against him.
He was very nearly
successful in defeating them,
but following the naval
battle of Trafalgar,
Napoleon's plans to conquer Britain were
put aside and he focused on continental
Europe instead.
However,
Napoleon was finally defeated in 1815
it's really around this time that 800
years following the Norman
conquest of England,
the infamous Anglo French
rivalry begins to wind down.
Europe entered into a period sometimes
referred to as packs for Tanika for
British peace lasting from 1815 to
1914 in which very few major wars were
fought.
Britain was the world's leading power
in this time and pursued it's imperial
ambitions.
And while France did indeed to bill
the colonial empire and remained a very
powerful and influential nation,
it never really challenged Britain
again and the ways it had in the past.
In fact,
the Napoleonic wars were really the
last time Britain and France went to war
with each other from here on out. In
fact, they'd be fighting on the same side,
which was foreshadowed by their joint
efforts in the Crimean war against Russia.
And so this great rivalry started to
come to a close after 1815 the two power
started to set aside their differences
and even began to work together.
But why?
Well,
there are a number of reasons
that cooperation would be
strategically favorable,
but the big reason occurring in the latter
half of the 18 hundreds was Germany.
Germany,
for most of its history,
consisted of a collection of fragmented
microstates called the Holy Roman Empire
with Austria and Prussia being the only
nations within that empire capable of
projecting power beyond their
borders to a major extent.
By the 18 hundreds most of
the old European nations
were experiencing some form
of major change,
including Germany.
In 1871 pressure had won that debate
against Austria over who would be the
master of the German lands and then
defeated France in a war allowing the
Germans to unify and evolved into the
modern nation. We note the day as Germany,
Germany wasted no time and throwing
its weight around and quickly establish
itself as a major power.
This was naturally worrying to Britain
and France and they decided it would be
in their best interest to set aside
their differences to prevent Germany from
taking advantage of any weaknesses.
The awkward new found friendship between
Britain and France was cemented when
they stood together as allies in both
world wars and continue to during the Cold
War and into the modern day as the two
nations still largely find cooperation to
be in their best interest with their
tents. Rivalries long behind them,
though the modern age has seen Britain
and France work as partners and some
parts of the world, the remnants of
Anglo French enmity can still be found.
The most obvious example of
this is in North America,
specifically in Canada when the British
defeated the French and the French and
Indian war and North America,
they took the majority of its main
land holdings except for Louisiana,
which was given this Spain and later
sold to the United States. However,
the British were not successful
and assimilating the local
French populations of
the territory which they annexed,
and these people are the people
we know today as French Canadians.
I planned the cover this
more in a future video,
but the term French Canadian tends to
refer to the descendants of the French
colonists in North America prior
to the seven years' war in general,
they typically see themselves
as their own group,
less related to the European French.
So if someone immigrated
from France to Canada today,
they wouldn't really be considered as a
part of the same cultural linguistic or
even ethnic group in the United States.
Though in some parts the country,
the language is still spoken
and the culture remains alive.
Ethnic French Canadians such as those
who history was in Louisiana or Michigan
and those who immigrated later including
my family are largely assimilated as
full Americans in Canada.
However,
French culture remains distinct from
British Canadian culture historically and
Quebec and Acadia in particular,
the French Canadian people have emphasized
marrying only within their group,
remaining Catholic and retaining
their culture and language.
Despite external forces are not
quite this strict these days.
This resilience is why the French presence
in North America did not disappear.
In fact, it nearly led to a split
in Canada on multiple occasions.
The most famous incident being in
1995 when Quebec took a vote on its
independence,
the wheat vote amounted to 49.42% of the
population with no amounting to 50.58%
a very close vote and the issue is still
debated to this day a conflict stemming
for almost a thousand years
and the solutions to concerns
as far back as the 17
hundreds still in some areas remain
unresolved and hotly debated.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
If you did come check out some of my
other stuff and subscribed to see more
informative videos in the future.
I have another documentary
projects coming up soon.
A complete history of the Roman empire,
so stay tuned for that to help
with the cost of production.
Fire of learning does
take donations on Patrion,
the link to which you can
find in the description.
Even just a $1 contribution
helps to support the channel,
and you'll even get your name up here
with these guys. Thank you for watching.